يتارجح الشارع التونسي في خضم تعقيدات
مختلفه مع استمرار السيال بين الرئيس قيس
سعيد ومعارضيه يوما بعد اخر ينتقل الوضع
من تعقيد لاخر مع تاكيد السعيد مضيه قدما
فيما وصفه بانقاذ الدوله وبانه لن يتراجع
ابدا في المقابل يتنامى التحرك المعارض
على خلفيه حمله اعتقالات
واستدعاءات تشتد
نغيب الصحفيين واحد ممن يواجهون التهم من
قبل الدوله وصف ما يجري بانه محرقه ضد
حريه الراي اما رئيس جبهه الخلاص احمد
نجيب الشابي الذي مات معظم شركائه في
القياده معتقلين قال ان الحمله اصبحت تعم
كل الاوصاد ولا تستثني احدا وهو حديث
لاحقه اعتقال قيادي اخر في جبهته جوهر
مبارك واتهمه التامر على الدوله
حركه النهضه التي يستمر استدعاء زعيمها
راشد الغنوشي للتحقيقات قالت انما يجري هو
ملاحقه لرموز المعارضه والناشطين بتهم
وصفتها بانها مزيفه وملفقه ودعت القضاء
الى عدم الانصياع لضغوط السلطه واطلاق
سراح موقوفين بينما استنكر الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل ما قال انه ابعاد للقظام
مناصبهم وتهديد لامنهم وحياتهم ويرفض
الاتحاد كل محاولات الزيج بالنقابيين في
السجون
من القذافي تحت الهرسله القضاء فيها
يستعمل ويهدد واذا ما يمشيش الظالمات
القاضي احنا مع قضاء مستقله وهنا يحضر ملف
القضاء حيث برزت مجددا قضيه القاضي
المعزول البشير العكرمي بعد ان حذر محاميه
من امكانيه اخراج موكله بالقوه واختطافه
بعد محاصره قوى الامن لمستشفى الامراض
النفسيه والعقليه الذي يعالج فيه مخاوف
عززها العكرمي بتسجيل من داخل المستشفى
[موسيقى]
وبعد العلاج
المستمره ولكن
نطاق التونسي
ان حمله الاعتقالات تنفذ لاعتبارات سياسيه
وانها محاوله متعمده للتضييق على منتقد
الرئيس سعيد وسياساته بينما وصفت منظمه
هيومن رايتس الاعتقالات بانها محمله
برساله من الرئيس تغلق باب الانتقاد
والمعارضه